[Musique]
la corée à équiper tous les téléphones
et les données personnelles de ce qui
était nécessaire pour prévenir tout
l'entourage lorsqu'une personne était
malade
est ce que vous êtes très mal à monod à
suivre la corée jusqu'au bout de sa
démarche
moi je n'en suis pas convaincu y à titre
personnel je vous le dis non plus
[Rires]
[Musique]
singapour 2 montre d'une part que je
crois 10 7% seulement des singapouriens
qui ont un esprit de corps probablement
supérieur renault ont adopté cette
technologie et d'autre part on à la 70 %
des français qui ont un smartphone donc
ça revient à dire qu'il faudrait que
près de 9 français sur 10 possesseurs
d'un smartphone l'adoptent de patients
volontaires donc en l'état elle ne peut
pas être efficace
[Musique]